en ese lugar se han declarado En paro
indefinido en contra de la presidenta
Dina boluarte el congreso y la clase
política de este país que nosotros
venimos organizados de manera mes más
nosotros salimos de a pie no estamos yo
no pertenezco a ningún gremio a ninguno
soy una persona que sale de su casa y
alza su voz Como cada uno de nuestros
hermanos también participan y dan a
conocer este esta empatía esta situación
de asesinato que han venido tomando las
fuerzas policiales y militares de parte
del gobierno el Primer Ministro Alberto
tarola ha dicho que no van a ceder al
chantaje de la violencia y que van a
emplear toda la fuerza de la ley para
restablecer la seguridad de los peruanos
no les tenemos miedo porque nosotros no
somos no somos como nos han tildado
delincuentes no somos terroristas somos
gente que el único la única arma que
tenemos es nuestra voz de protesta una
voz de protesta en la cual nos ampara la
Constitución que es una una constitución
hecha también al antojo del gobierno de
Alberto fujimori una constitución que la
han hecho solo para saquearlo al Perú
así como esta región la zona extensa en
otros puntos del país donde existen vías
bloqueadas que solamente serán abiertas
para trasladar la protesta a Lima la
capital peruana